[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très simple se pose des questions
et tu vas devoir répondre tout ce que te
dit laurent baffie dans ton oreille
d'accord sans leur titre tu étais dans
l'émission on a tout essayé avec laurent
ruquier qu'on embrasse il tresse son
corps un truc que tu as pas essayer oui
la double peine et al arabia will do le
pesnel arrabiata ouais merci oui toi qui
connais bien laurent baffie quelle est
la pire crainte qu'il était fait demandé
à ma fille comment tu arrives à
convaincre les artistes pour qu'ils
viennent à ta soirée de la nuit de la
déprime j'ai des dossiers sur tout le
monde je la fait chanter pour qu'ils
viennent chanter j'ai des dossiers sur
tout le monde va je les fais chanter
pour guillaume chantier alors tu fais la
nuit la déprime c'est quoi ta solution
contre la déprime dont je me masturbe en
pensant à arlette chabot ça apporte quoi
de bosser avec patrick sébastien
je serai tout les [ __ ] dubois
voleurs prennent un bon bah je connais
tous les travaux du bois par leur prénom
après la nuit de la déprime c'est quoi
le thème de ta prochaine soirée alors
ben je crois qu'on va faire la nuit des
petites bêtes étaient cordialement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec des amis des soirées entendre un
praticien où il va aller au combat
beat informatique un moment il ya
quelqu'un qui va nous parler moi de le
faire
y'a quelqu'un qui va lui dire avec
toutes les cassettes et dvd vendus de
thé caméra cachée tu dois être riche
quand même quel point tu es riche il me
manque 20 euros pour baiser de divine
il me manquait pour 20 euros pour baiser
ludivine ciel ludivine attend donc 30
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
obliger les gens à la télé ou en radio
tu excelles dans quel autre domaine
je rêve je repère immédiatement les cons
alors je veux dire un truc je repère
immédiatement les combats brélaz
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la même interview et brad pitt alors
brad pitt il a quoi de plus que les
autres boîtes rien parce qu'il a même
pas baisé la copine de bâti que toi tu
as baiser alors rien parce qu'il a même
pas busy la copine de baffie que toi tu
as baiser
merci
[Applaudissements]